[Musique]
je m'appelle Pascal Le Floch dirigeant
de PLF coaching alors j'ai démarré mon
activité en février de cette année je
fais partie je dirais d'une coopérative
qui s'appelle la forge et ça me permet
d'être au sein d'un réseau
d'entrepreneurs la Forge est située en
fait sur le bassin de Saint-Quentin à
Coignières
j'accompagne les entrepreneurs les
dirigeants les managers avec leurs
équipes et en ce qui concerne la
formation là je m'appuie sur mes 17 ans
de management des 25 ans de carrière en
commercial pour justement transmettre
mais savoir-faire mes techniques
également donc le coach lui va faire
tout ce qu'il est en mesure de faire
pour amener son client ou sa cliente à
passer à l'action
l'aspect formation pour l'instant c'est
60% de des revenus et l'aspect coaching
qui est en augmentation représente
aujourd'hui 40% à 6 mois d'activité
c'est je dirais que c'est au-delà de mes
espérances mais j'ai déjà fait des
cycles de formation pour des entreprises
internationales pour leurs équipes de
vente et par rapport à l'aspect coaching
j'ai démarré avec mon réseau direct et
le bouche à oreille fonctionne bien
puisque les premiers clients me
recommandent
il y a un programme sur lequel je suis
en train de travailler de construire ça
sera vraiment ma signature l'aspect
performance
un sérénité et équilibre s'agit tient
énormément parce qu'en fait c'est ce qui
m'a permis moi pendant plus de 20 ans de
rester en forme mais aussi d'atteindre
mes objectifs et d'être surtout en
équilibre entre ma vie pro ma vie privée
ma vie sociale notre idée en
développement c'est l'aspect coaching
d'équipe et il y a ce besoin d'échange
la magie en fait du groupe intelligence
collective qui joue et j'ai vraiment
envie de d'apporter ma pierre à
l'édifice dans ce domaine
[Musique]